almost tough that's what that is a now
familiar scene
in a rapidly escalating crisis
while america was distracted by an
election an epidemic surged
in michigan people queued for up to four
hours to get tested
the state's embarking on a three-week
lockdown no schools colleges or in
dining restaurants can open
there's resignation but resistance too
i'm just glad i'm not trying to make a
living trump would have been a lot
fairer but you know
that's that's the way it goes i'm a
little uh disappointed
shall we say in the side that doesn't
apparently doesn't respect science and
doesn't respect the need for this type
of thing
why do you think some people are so
against it
one word trump deaths from covert 19 in
michigan alone
are up 150 on what they were just two
weeks ago
there's a real sense here things are
spiraling and leaders aren't shying away
from stringent action
no matter how divisive or unpopular
this is now a pandemic politicized the
financial toll already hangs heavy here
there'll be no national lockdown
according to trump
restrictions being wielded by largely
democrat local lawmakers
freedom it's enraging to some
this wasn't a large group outside the
state capital but their presence speaks
to palpable tension
and distrust you've been told no by the
people you've been told no by the
supreme court and you're continuing to
do this and people aren't going to stand
for it
and you know just like i said right now
we're the rational people
if you keep pushing out you're going to
get irrational people and we don't want
that well
we're gonna do everything in our power
to try the peaceful route
but when it comes to our livelihoods and
our rights that we are born with as
humans we're not gonna budge
would you turn to violence if my life
was threatened
and my rights are threatened
but the protection of lives means threat
to livelihoods
under the new restrictions bars like
stephanie's will be forced to close
she doesn't have a safety net and she's
fearful and frustrated
this should have been over you know we
potentially could have
not had these numbers and do you feel
quite stressed about it all my savings
are gone
my bills are coming up you know my dog
needs surgery and i'm like
okay you know
but at the same time i get it
joe biden said he'll step up work to
stem the virus and bring communities
together
neither will be easy helen ann smith sky
news
lansing michigan